fue un día histórico en eeuu al
iniciarse el segundo juicio político
contra donald trump
fue ser republicanos en el senado se
pusieron del lado de los demócratas para
dictaminar que el proceso es
constitucional por lo tanto pueden
seguir adelante los republicanos habían
argumentado que tu am no puede ser
condenado porque ya no ocupa el cargo
los demócratas dijeron que esa lógica
sienta un peligroso precedente y daría
carta blanca a cualquier presidente para
actuar con impunidad constitucional en
sus últimas semanas en el cargo
y abrieron sus comentarios mostrando un
vídeo de los disturbios del 6 de enero
en el capitolio hecho que llevó a
iniciar el juicio contra el ex
presidente jacques preguntan que es un
alto crimen y un delito menor según
nuestra constitución eso es lo que es un
alto crimen y un delito menor si eso no
es un delito juzgable entonces no existe
tal cosa
después de la emoción al cierre del
primer argumento fue el turno de los
abogados defensores de trump en un
desconcertante
de apertura de 50 minutos el primer
representante legal de su am no presentó
en su mayoría ninguna refutación legal a
los demócratas de la cámara de
representantes en un momento dado
admitieron que habían cambiado de
táctica tras escuchar los argumentos
iniciales de la oposición luego pasaron
al ataque
entendamos por qué estamos aquí
realmente estamos aquí porque la mayoría
de estas personas nos quieren
enfrentarse a donald trump como rival
político en el futuro por eso estamos
aquí en el film resurgir otros senadores
partidarios de trump argumentaron que
era el odio hacia el ex presidente lo
que estaba alimentando el juicio
advirtiendo que sólo acabaría
desgarrando el país